I feel like it's quite rare to meet
someone who's an in-house personal slave
to someone right right you wouldn't
bring out the suitors to me
don't miss that we'll see you're about
to see a lot kind of feel bad that he's
in the cage just a warning to everyone
out there hello thank you
tattoo just about fees peanuts put it on
the test setting you can look at me one
last time before I blindfold you never
collaborated a human before it's
normally just leftovers you want to take
your shirt off and welcome do you cheap
would allow that I don't know what I
would do without this life
[Music]
hi there I'm Tom and I'm about to spend
24 hours with damiana who is obsessed
with power control subs domes whips
chains dungeons and the psychology of
the human mind
I first became obsessed with the subject
of BDSM about 20 years ago through a
psychological standpoint I was assigned
in my master's degree in psychology to
choose a disorder out of the Diagnostic
and Statistical Manual of Mental
Disorders most of them sounded
depressing so I chose the city of
masochism well I ended up writing my
doctoral dissertation on the subject I
just started writing paper after paper
about it I think there's a difference
between having a fetish and being
obsessed with it and when you have an
in-house slave isn't in your dungeon for
over a decade this is kind of like
bordering obsession right and obviously
he is obsessed with the opposite side of
this spectrum he is a big bottom I feel
like I'm gonna end up leaving Demi Ana's
dungeon feeling like his biggest vanilla
piece of and I can't wait
I see - you should like me to show you
around room by room there's a medical
fantasy strap people to it
interrogation chair something specials
gonna happen here today that's never
been done maybe we'll leave that as a
surprise for later yeah I'm a nine to
five doll maybe my first sessions around
ten o'clock in the morning and I might
end in the late afternoon of your early
evening and then my goal is to be done
by that time so I can go home and make
dinner for my children take them to
ballet lessons piano all of these things
are very important to me what about this
here the spanking bench would you like
to you know maybe in a minute yeah are
you definitely sure right now that what
are you gonna teach me today so there's
a lot involved as far as imparting
knowledge about the psychology behind
BDSM show you how to carry yourself how
to speak there needs to be three
elements for a dominatrix to be well
balanced this seductress the mother and
the authoritarian oh yeah come out here
so you be kind of assisting me okay you
just mold me I'm just my nerd right now
sure I'll be fine
yeah Mike might be in earshot right now
haha go I'm gonna talk to me lo I'm da
me on a personal slave because it's his
birthday my sister is going to come over
yo sista Jezebel is a dumb as well she
is yeah we are known as the cheese
sisters uh-huh and we are going to
finally collar him today he's going to
get tattooed and then I've got a client
of mine coming in putting him in bondage
and you up for it
but everyone brilliant yeah perfect he
said into like heavy workings and heavy
bondage and such give my plate things
most definitely and then we're going to
have my slave girl come in Thank You mr.
smiley play with her as well I'm her
mistress get on your knees
yes mr. sort of owner and friend I've
got
cleaning slave like mr. psychic I'm
gonna have him start cleaning everything
getting it ready for you for the
sleepover while we go to dinner you know
he can do that
am i okay dressed like this would you
like to get dressed with us there are
some boundaries that Charlotte to be
crust something Beyonce would wet I
don't even know what this is oh it's
another cat suit it looks good this is
the best pad coloring was banging in the
kitchen okay okay
I'm calming on his personal slave I'm
exclusive to her on your knees say your
property yes
and so this dungeon is home this is home
this is a special day it's your birthday
we've planned a little special
activities for you today we want to
officially you call her you as her slave
today slated Mike property of the
cheese's oh yes great you belong to us
now yeah they're our family
we adore you and you're special to us
did you emotional your mistresses came
out with your color that was a very
emotional moment
yes yeah I would say it was like you
know euphoria yeah 10 for your birthday
spanking 17 spanks too simple a
[Music]
thank you thank you on to the next thing
on the agenda yes for your birthday
we're just gonna do to you probably
reemerged don't resist it just go into
it
you've done that before just do the same
thing I'm tying in soccer balls and
pulling them down why do you think pain
feels so good
I don't like we think it feels good it's
like but you're suffering for your
mistress but pain just for pain sake I
never really really liked it's fun I can
imagine like as time goes on the bar
just I get a little concerned that I've
done everything yeah I was gonna on us
do you ever get bored are you ever like
this again I've been bullwhipped a
thousand times what next yeah a little
although you never know what's gonna
happen in way that keeps you in a little
suspense yeah so I was thinking to do a
little flogging lesson a good idea for a
Dom to feel the submissive side you get
a better understanding good okay are you
really yep
okay
across place your hands here so you
don't want the flogger to go like this
and wrap around this is the lightest
lager that I have I'm just gonna figure
eight everybody's sexuality is on a
spectrum of the dominance and
submissiveness and you know you might be
kind of twitchy and have both or you're
more on the submissive side want to take
your shirt off
welcome you know I think everything is
scary before you try it yourself what do
you think are some common misconceptions
that it's dark abusive
thing that people do is they will you
know there is some darkness but it's
only there when if someone wants it BDSM
is consensual because it's safe sane and
consensual and that's how I play I'm
gonna change to a different outfit
because the mood
my next session is different you know a
little bit more fierce I'm gonna wear a
hat like you whoa-ho mr. stack she just
wants to feel but she hasn't actually
done it
you know he could fake it but we need to
warm him up so how you went from
flogging the out of Mac the hugging
him it's a really bonding experience I
would have never thought that dominating
was so nurturing the more you're
submissive feels safe in your control
the economy names the more they let go
it's all about trust I feel like very
open very much the same when you
meditate you feel very good I think
she's very intuitive person and I think
she's a healing soul as well there's no
barriers barriers with the rest of the
world only there are going to be people
that are imbalanced and they're maybe
using it as an outlet but there are a
lot of psychologically imbalance people
in the world who use other things as
outlets never glad rented a human before
it's normally just leftovers and
actually recent research now they've
found that people who play in BDSM are
actually more psychologically healthy
than people who aren't they're actually
accepting those parts of themselves
that's when you're psychologically
healthy person the less you suppress the
healthier you are
[Music]
why did we act that way I didn't want to
be afraid conditioning what conditioning
go over here
my cleaning slaves about your live
mistress you have your car tap use
mistress time to you today clean all the
toys that we used these here make
everything neat my sister she had an
acquaintance that was doing kind of like
slave stuff for her he would come over
to my house a me to clean my house he
pays you yeah he would pay me to clean
my house what a dream that's so fun how
about we get something to eat yes yes
sobbing yeah so my slave you put all the
clean toys in one place in it do you
ever wish that you let a fully vanilla
life that you want obsessive BDSM I
don't know what I would do without this
life I'm so grateful for it mm-hmm I
feel so lucky
[Music]
to do to leave Roxy she's my female
plaything she's great I love her fill it
will we be doing the Spanky maybe a
paddling she's discovered a part of her
son that's
kind of already been there but it's
being awakened kind of like what
happened with you yeah I think so
on the dominant and you know I don't
think she would mind if you spanked her
as well what are you I'm not actually
sure he's done an excellent job do you
still have things to do actually in
finishing mistress there's one mistake
you see I want you to spray it come out
here yeah get down on your knees
you know I'm going to report to your
owner
what a terrible job you did on my
loyalty owed you to lean over that's
Maggie Carson if she hadn't done a good
job no it's kind of very sick my pilot
looks that way having you might guess
Turner
the puppy appreciates your strictness
because it needs you to teach it that
way so it's not my pride just like the
puppy in any way he needs
sturdiness it's been a big day just
excited to meet a female sub
slight Roxy maybe you could go for her
how you spank is you cup your hands a
little like this it makes a better sound
too when you great thank you
thank you mister she brings out
something different in me Roxy was so
happy yeah it feels like guys making in
another level it takes me to a whole
nother level mentally she always
surprises me with how much I can take
and the life I can feel especially
because I'm really like asexual in my
personal life so to be able to explore
here and feel the pain through pleasure
it's exciting I'm ready for the day but
I'm going to bed rah thank you
it's almost midnight Roxy's about to
leave she's getting dressed and likes
getting ready to go to sleep in the cage
nature's goodness I want to put you to
bed now because your birthday
so much happened it feels like we've
been invited into this very secret
private wall they're entrusting me and
the biggest secret that they have you
know possibly a secret that nobody else
in their life knows it's a big deal
it's a big deal yeah to be honest top
and last night I was
very anxious because I don't know how
this would go down and just want to be
somebody else just for a day it relies
completely on consent trust and
communication I can kind of understand
down how you would become obsessed one
day you get flogged the next day you get
spanked
and of course you'd be like well what's
next anyone you want to get the right
week I kind of feel bad that he's in the
cage I would sleep here always if she
would request that well it's always
you're comfortable and warm mm-hmm Mikey
well happy birthday thank you very much
I was glad you were here to see it and
yeah it was a lot of fun all right well
good night good night
[Music]
has it been hard to find partners or
friends understand that obsession my
husband I actually met in the scene so
we actually built all my dungeon
furniture well that's how we met
obsessed might have this connotation of
only all into that but you know my
obsession is very healthy I'm expressing
myself as a complete woman it's just the
greatest this is much more fulfilling
for me than my psychotherapy practice
that I almost went into there's a
limited relationship there we have to
stay behind this barrier there's
or I honor people to do that but this is
I have a cool job because I get to meet
a lot of people they show me very
intimate parts of their lives but I feel
like this is really up there so thank
you so much for sharing that with a
welcome it was an honor for me to be
with you and show you my life mm-hmm I'm
proud of it you seem very happy
I'm very happy I wish everyone can
experience what I experienced it's not
for everyone it's definitely for me
[Music]
you